la bella paris jazz ragazzi allora vi
spiego molto calma mente come cosa fare
allora
quando noi vi spiego come funziona il
gioco allora il massimo 3 minuti per
round stato ma come funziona sta roba
queste google maps ma ho capito ho
capito in stand by a jurman doloranti
siamo in due quindi due cervelli popolo
però teste di co2 almeno al
moltiplicatore no se poi c'è un cartello
volevo leggere non c'è più cartello
pappano di case sicure allora
effettivamente non so dove potremo
essere abbiamo tre minuti per ora il
parabrezza di questo tizio tanto va bene
e lo scotch minuti la prima volta bene
per i bimbi per i bimbi
la prima vogliamo sicuramente penso che
si candida come allora facciamo italia o
questo quando andavamo noi è l'arena di
verona questa qua ma questa l'ho vista
una volta in e giorgio cose o con
pungente si fa i salti dentro al
colosseo
credo che sia il colosseo non ne sono
completamente sicuro andare sul colosseo
ma è almeno una direi che ce la portiamo
a casa nelle colazioni settimane anche
centrale il punto le corse tra l'altro
ieri quindi la parte alta di quaglia è
perfettamente che la parte alta e questa
e quindi saremo indicativamente questo
pasticcio 5 di parma mia di un'armeria
11 mesi la chiamo cinque volte abbiamo
avuto
bene allora santa maria
[Musica]
lì ho visto un banco di sicilia non so
se manco ci sono e moglie rosaria
secondo me sem in sicilia qua orco mio
quando tu sei le selezioni personali su
warcraft che c'è di nani loro re e
miglior comino dai una scritta di me
perfetto quasiasi cosa migliore
sicuramente mappe come entrata la mappa
di google laden a 32 a dai ragazzi prego
dai un minimo ma se noi abbiamo andiamo
a randomiche niente faranno sempre loro
niente salta di qua come hai un'altra
sembra una delle nostre
quella di prima così sono ancora in
prima di un'altra è un'altra che i denti
che ci hanno fatto il copia incolla è un
paese pieno mi chiese questo non lo so
raga non abbiamo di nociglia fisso bravi
quello promessi più o meno da quella
pagata e tu hai letto
no secondo me siamo in sicilia e allora
metterei si guarda guarda lì da jean
aiutaci tosi a me sicilia qua no però
non penso mi sa di no però ho detto non
è eletto non c'entra niente con la
escluderei a priori
secondo me vedi che qua ci sono un po
più di montagne quindi saremo tipo 45
che guarda che andava guarda che c hai
avuto un bel ragionamento però sì perché
così la noce nero agenzia complesso è
stato un casino fase
ecco essere spiccioli complessa materia
lanciavo di una maniera difficilissimo
per sé via torino che cacchio sia
correnti cioè saperi come su di milano
umbra tengono quindi niente rari e
saremo vaglio le macchine però
marciapiedi quindi sì siamo a milano
comunque ma lavora qua guarda tipo qui
deve essere da quelle parti
vai visto 402 merce nove metri a vera
che avviene a dare altro 102 metri di
linea d'aria c'era ma va bene qua e tre
le amiche ma allora in realtà potrebbe
potrebbe confondersi sai te perché io
non vedo vette altissime onestamente nel
codice di borse qua lo sapevo leggere
l'arte deve essere tranquillamente la
sicilia è infatti d'altro dove stavamo
guardando prima c'è incredibile è il
punto più lontano dell'italia dove
abbiamo schiacciato bravi complimenti e
le palme qua siamo in liguria come stato
in sicilia ma potrebbe essere noi sempre
sicilia c'è il mare hanno visto viene
dal mare attenzione all attenzione
matera matera mera sicilia e tutti
sappiamo che materia
e in sicilia esatto puglia forse ma te
la palla quando sarà quello quando
questo baraccone
sì ma non c'erano alla luna marte quale
c'è un italia tranne uno totalmente a
caso gli altri abbiano abbastanza secca
ti va bene
cambiamo mappa ma la vedo piante fin lì
ci siamo allora se viaggia sulla
sinistra è il terzo la struttura della
messa dignità sia anche secondo me ne
sai rio bravo bravo si potrebbe partire
da quella parola marocco vice e come 7
zacchetti somale è dovuta di provocare
sì perché giocare vuol dire che prima
del 31 tensione non lo azzecco ma se lo
azzecco potrebbe darsi ma nasce
transport e non si capisce niente in
arabo o in libia di via libia mamma mia
attenzione dove sono pranzo pre sopra
questa questa è la libia mario non è la
libia era quello arca vacca ti è
sicuramente il nord hanno indovinato i
nordafrica gitto no ci hanno già provato
sudan qua dentro si sudano santissima
eritrea
ma porca vacca porca porca vacca
comunque in due
continuiamo a farci buttare fuori di
geografia e lo spiega la stamattina in
live
io faccio pagare forse potrebbe essere
non vorrei dire una cazzata ma potrebbe
essere il già forte
e allora si è sicuramente asiatica come
situazione
mamma mia il marola le solite dal dalle
mura transito la di riconoscere i posti
devono la loro storia architettura dove
cazzo se la conformità dei mattoni
guarda qua praticamente ho fatto così ho
guardato qua dove si anche la struttura
effettivamente della casa è già
interamente giapponese si sembra la
prima a fano
ovviamente cioè ci sono ville così anche
lì no vietcong optik
si no sì dai
questa è una tabella questa bene perché
prima ancora che uscisse questa sera
sbagliati ma rinuncio primo primo
contenuto caricato
ma che cos'è il giro la bibbia gerlando
alieni o infissi porto italia italia
subito infissi porte ed infissi porte se
non evita gelateria pasticceria e anche
la mia palermo sia funk sai dove
l'italiano c'era locata da un chilometro
e mezzo ma quando sarà ottimo tool
giocavamo in casa raga ma non me l'ha
presa perché io avevo visto che mi
locata scusa
hai votato due volte italia non è quella
rimini e rimini non è italia
assolutamente casa venuti antica san
marino non mi dire non ci credono
pazzesco non ci credo se pensate che non
ci guarda non ci posso credere o ma
leggeri pensate c'era l'unico punto
stava in quel vaticano pensano sugli
appalti
i due c'era veramente mamma mia non è
l'italia
rimini dove che azzeri non era lì ma dai
ma dai ma dai ma lo catania moltissimo
lo zio di moret è fortissimo lo zio
lavorare mare è fortissimo lo sia
veramente munita di grecia può essere
sono soldi aspettare un po
se loca e fortissima questo qua è
fortissimo c'è veramente allocato anche
romania non sono affatto amos resort
potrebbe essere ammessa di grecia ma ok
[Musica]